[Musica]
allora dai ragazzi cominciamo subito con
un quiz di genetica difficile vediamo
come ve la cavate in questa simpatica
famiglia che è il padre biologico del
bambino
vediamo un po chi chi vuole indovinare i
da idraulici vuota per l'idraulico chi
vota per il papa nessuno 1 fiducioso è
l'idraulico va per la maggiore è strano
ogni volta che faccio questo quiz ea
tutti votano per l'idraulico avete fatto
un esperimento di genetica non vi sto
prendendo in giro
e vero a perché avete usato le
conoscenze di genetica che sono nella
nostra testa nella nostra cultura senza
sapere niente del dna a tutti noi
dall'alba dei tempi sappiamo che esiste
un'ereditarietà quindi genitori e figli
si somigliano nelle famiglie ci sono
delle somiglianze quindi non è proprio
una cosa scientifica perché poi invece
se uno va a fare un test del dna
magari scopre i risultati diversi però
dai ve la siete cavata fatevi un
applauso dai sette stati abbastanza poi
dopo facciamo un altro esperimento
questo sono io
nel secolo scorso nel intorno al 1995
era un giovane ricercatore come vedete
pieno di speranze e di energia per il
futuro
non ero bello ma non ero neanche
bruttissimo il dramma di noi biologi
molecolari era che eravamo
infrequentabili eravamo considerati dei
super nerd
la cosa che noi studiavamo cioè dna
veniva vista come roba da laboratorio da
camici bianchi
ogni tanto capitava di andare magari a
una festa e arrivava una ragazza col
bicchiere in mano ti chiedeva beh tutti
cosa ti occupi appena pronunciare la
parola dna girava i tacchi e spariva
eravamo veramente considerati qualche
uno dei dei topi di laboratorio
adesso le cose sono cambiate intanto voi
siete qui siete in tanti e fra le altre
cose siete venuti anche a sentire
parlare
non potete scappare perché le uscite di
sicurezza sono state bloccate in questa
occasione però è successo nel frattempo
qualcosa che ha reso il dna una cosa
molto molto diversa e successo questo
sto per rivelarvi i risultati del mio
test del dna che bt che mantiene il vvx
vietati mi hai detto impedire e rovi ho
mai nelle stesso shaun the walking tieni
d'aiutolo roxy e sono troppo si nota
perché i risultati del mio test del dna
del mio account in pakistan
e i risultati stavano la cosa succede
migliaia centinaia di migliaia milioni
oggi di persone che vanno su internet
acquistano una lettura online del loro
dna
e poi non solo una volta che hanno
risultato vanno su youtube persone di
tutti i tipi studenti giovani vecchi di
tutto il mondo e o su youtube su
facebook sui social e raccontano la loro
esperienza
il dna non solo diventa qualcosa che è
uscito dai laboratori ed entrato nelle
nostre case è diventato qualcosa che ha
un contenuto social e adesso vedremo
anche di che cosa si tratta
il dna da cosa roba da topi di
laboratorio è diventata una cosa e
devo dire che anche la mia vita sociale
un pochino
ci ha guadagnato poco
come funziona beh si va su internet
esistono ormai in decine dozzine di siti
che offrono questi servizi si va su
internet con la carta di credito si
acquista un kit che ti arriva a casa una
scatolina come questa un budget
dentro questo kit c'è uno di questi
proiettori che avete visto nel filmato
ci si sputa dentro pensate un viaggio
così tecnologico inizia con uno sputo
con la cosa più semplice del mondo si
spedisce lo sputo al laboratorio dove
viene estratto il dna e viene analizzato
decodificato l'ho fatto anch'io sono
anch'io uno spettatore e dopo un paio di
settimane mi arriva una email che mi
dice caro sergio il tuo profilo genetico
è pronto con la tua username e la tua
password
accedi al sito alla tua pagina e inizia
a navigare nel tuo dna proprio così
navigare nel tuo dna
io non l'avevo mai fatto una cosa che
succede al mio sputo e quindi al mio dna
durante questo viaggio è qualcosa di
straordinario che non ha precedenti
nella storia ed è il cuore di quello che
vi racconto oggi il mio dna viene
decodificato con delle tecniche che
ovviamente adesso non vi sto a
raccontare e le sue componenti chimiche
che sono delle lettere che amate base
nucleotidiche ce ne sono 4 ag ct e ne
abbiamo 3,2 miliardi nel nostro genoma
quindi nel nostro dna
vengono lette decodificate e trasformate
in un file
questo passaggio è fondamentale il
contenuto delle nostre cellule del
nostro organismo si duplica in una forma
extracorporea
da questo momento in poi io non ho solo
più il dna che sta dentro al mio corpo
ma ne ho una versione digitale extra
corporea che può fare tutti il viaggio
di di tutti i file che noi usiamo in
rete può andare su internet può entrare
in un social network può essere
duplicato e condiviso all'infinito
questo è un passaggio davvero epocale
per esempio io vado in giro con questa
chiavetta usb
dove dentro c'è un file con il mio dna
l'ho scaricato dal sito perché si può
fare è un file che contiene il mio
profilo genetico e l'ha praticamente la
versione digitale del mio dna
cosa posso fare con questo file beh
posso fare delle cose che prima erano
impossibili una cosa è questa questo è
il facebook del mio dna
io qualche anno fa ho scritto un libro
che si intitola il dna incontra facebook
dove parlavo proprio dell'alba della
della genomica digitale e dei social
network genomici e in qualche libraio mi
ha detto che il libro veniva messo nel
reparto fantascienza perché
evidentemente pensavano che fosse
qualcosa di molto futuribile
io ho insistito naturalmente sulla sul
fatto che questa cosa
esisteva davvero e il facebook del mio
dna
e proprio qui in questa diapositiva
questa funzione si chiama trova parenti
e fa esattamente quello che dice il nome
il mio file di dna viene confrontato col
file di dna di tutti gli altri clienti
del sito e là dove emerge una parentela
fino al quinto al quinto grado quindi
fino al cugino di quinto grado fra i
nostri dna il sistema a me lo segnala
adesso io ho questa questa bacheca dove
vedete nella prima colonna ci sono dei
profili di persone con foto a volte nome
e cognome informazione che io
naturalmente oscurato per tutelare la
loro privacy
nella seconda colonna il trova parenti
mi dice qual è il grado di parentela che
io ho con queste persone
nel mio caso ho trovato dei cugini fra
il terzo e quinto grado quindi lontani
cugini che stanno in giro per il mondo
l'ultima colonna a parte quella di mezzo
dove ci sono dei dati particolari
l'ultima colonna è la più interessante
perché là è la e il tastino per chiedere
l'amicizia
proprio come su facebook io posso
chiedere l'amicizia queste persone
loro lo fanno con me naturalmente l'ho
fatto anch'io e adesso io ho qualche
dozzina
i parenti lontani cugini sparse per il
mondo con cui non avrei mai avuto nessun
contatto se non fosse stato per il
confronto dei nostri dna questo come
potete capire è un vero e proprio social
network ha tutte le caratteristiche
l'unica cosa però che accomuna gli
utenti e il fatto di avere qualche
affinità nel nel dna è un social network
basato sui nostri geni ovviamente cosa
succederebbe qui io o se guardate c'è un
piccolo numero non si vede forse da
lontano però adesso io ho più di 800
parenti cugini sparsi per il mondo
adesso di più perché la slide e vecchia
1100 1200 cugini in giro per il mondo
io dico cugini però se io fossi
l'idraulico della prima della prima
slide e magari avessi qualche figlio
sparso in giro per il mondo o magari
fosse stato un donatore di sperma può
succedere potrebbe capitare che un bel
giorno uno di questi messaggi mi dice
caro papà sono tuo figlio
voglio conoscerti anche questo non è
fantascienza è una cosa che succede in
questi social network tant'è che
moltissimi ragazzi che sono stati
adottati o sono nati in provetta usano
in modo massiccio questi strumenti per
trovare i loro genitori biologici
un'altra cosa che posso fare con il mio
file e andare a ricercare le mie origini
genealogiche come in una scatola nera in
qualche modo nel mio dna c'è scritta la
storia della mia del mio lignaggio e
quando vado indietro nelle generazioni
come vedete io scopro che fino ai
trisnonni diciamo che posso fare
risalire la loro origine alitalia e poi
quando vado indietro nel tempo succede
quello che ci si aspetta e cioè che le
mie origini si sparpagliano in giro per
il mondo più andiamo indietro e più le
nostre origini
ovviamente sono mescolate questa è una
cosa che
sembra ovvia evidente io la riassumo
dicendo sono un bastardo genetico e lo
dico con orgoglio nel senso che sono un
miscuglio di tutte le etnie e di tutte
le popolazioni del mondo come tutti voi
qualcuno ancora questa lezione non l'ha
capita con risultati esilaranti
questo signore che vedete nella foto si
chiama cai polcom
ed è un razzista americano e il leader
di una formazione di suprematisti
bianchi quelli che dicono che i bianchi
sono superiori che esistono le razze
umane eccetera eccetera
questo signore ha avuto l'ottima idea di
andare a leggere il suo dna
però avuto la pessima idea di farlo in
televisione e questo è il risultato
com ren
[Applauso]
e mettiamo tutti senza
o no
sono successi con noi
[Applauso]
un applauso alla figuraccia di questo
povero signore che se avesse studiato un
po di genetica saprebbe benissimo che la
nostra specie e quindi homo sapiens
nasce 100 mila anni fa in africa e
quindi tutti noi anche voi se fate
questo test scoprite naturalmente di
avere un po di dna africano nei vostri
cromosomi e scoprite anche voi di essere
dei piccoli bastardi genetici cosa di
cui dovete andare orgogliosi quindi
questi strumenti sono una bellissima
dimostrazione che possiamo toccare tutti
con mano a casa nostra di come di quello
che i genetisti ripetono da anni cioè
non esistono le razze umane e ci
raccontano una lezione che forse appunto
in questi tempi vale la pena di
ricordare
grazie ricordiamoci basta parlare di dna
e parliamo di vino mi piace il vino che
vini preferiti e cabernet un bell
amarone della valpolicella
no perché c'è anche una applicazione su
internet che vi trova il vino adatto in
base al vostro dna
vogliate bene lo faccio non lo faccio
non c'è bisogno la facciamo
l'esperimento lo facciamo adesso tutti
insieme gratis quindi vi faccio
risparmiare anche qualche soldo
avete nella vostra bag una scatolina e
lo so nella bè che c'è un sacco di roba
ma dovreste avere una scatolina come
questa dove c'è scritto
sistemi e dietro c'è scritto aspetto
allo speaker giusto per aprire questa
scatola sono io
lo spi che giusto
pronti
allora attenzione perché dentro la
scatolina apritela con attenzione perché
trovate una caramella che sembra una
caramella in realtà è l'antidoto
all'esperimento e e una strisciolina di
carta questa e non la vedo ma
sicuramente il grande schermo la vedete
allora pronti pronti per l'esperimento
allora bisogna prendere questa cartina
cercate di produrre un po di saliva che
funziona meglio l'esperimento set e
saliva e poi niente la mente non anguria
tela e cercate di mettetela in bocca
come fosse una caramella
massaggiate la con il fondo della lingua
preferibilmente da 123 vedo già qualche
faccia
schifata allora sta facendo effetto sul
vostro corpo sul vostro organismo allora
attenzione
voglio sapere alzi la mano chi ha
sentito un sapore niente che ha sentito
il sapore della carta ok
alzi la mano chi ha sentito un sapore
amaro ok
amarissimo schifoso perfetto fatevi una
pausa perché anche questa volta
l'esperimento ha funzionato
adesso vi spiego in cosa consiste il
mondo si divide in gustatori e non
gustatori quelli che non sentono il
sapore sono naturalmente non gustatori e
quello che lo sentono l'amaro sono
gustatori poi ci sono i super gustatori
che lo sentono ancora più forte questo
dipende da un gene esiste un gene che
abbiamo tutti e che però esiste in
diverse versioni alcuni versioni
permettono di sentire questo sapore
amaro
altre invece sono neutre e non
permettono di sentire il sapore se io
leggo il vostro dna e questo sito che
che vi ho detto fa esattamente questo
legge il vostro dna e capisce dal vostro
dna
se avete questa versione del gene o meno
io infatti non ho assaggiato la cartina
come avete fatto voi perché so già che
sento questo sapore amaro molto forte
perché ho letto il mio dna e c'è scritto
che io sono un gustato re sembra una
stupidata in realtà ci dimostra qualcosa
di importante che esiste anche una
genetica delle preferenze in questo caso
delle preferenze alimentari
immaginatevi di sederci tutti insieme a
una bella tavolata in un ristorante
stellato
ordiniamo lo stesso menù stiamo
mangiando la stessa cosa ma in realtà
non stiamo mangiando la stessa cosa
perché ognuno di noi sentirà dei sapori
diversi in base al profilo genetico
faremo un test del dna prima di andare
al ristorante
può darsi chi lo sa di sicuro c'è
qualcosa di nuovo che prima non
e non sapevamo e visto che parliamo di
cibo volevo concludere con qualcosa
veramente di speciale che ho portato qui
e che riguarda il nostro dna ho voluto
portarvi quella che è la dimostrazione è
la forma più bella lampante di quello
che è il nostro dna attenzione perché e
ho dovuto l'ho dovuto apportare con
molta attenzione
ecco ok la vedete sul grande schermo un
biscotto il biscotto siamo noi
il dna è la ricetta del biscotto perché
parlo di una ricetta perché quello che
ci hanno insegnato a scuola sul dna e
questo e cioè il libro della vita
il progetto per la costruzione
dell'organismo
l'enciclopedia della degli esseri
viventi ok sono tutte immagini molto giù
suggestive che però rimandano a qualcosa
di molto deterministico il progetto di
questa di questo teatro è identico alla
versione finale cioè quello che vediamo
adesso non c'è differenza fra il
progetto è il prodotto finale
la ricetta è una cosa molto diversa la
ricetta un insieme di ingredienti che si
mescolano in modo caotico interagiscono
fra di loro interagiscono con l'ambiente
esterno e alla fine viene fuori un
prodotto che noi possiamo prevedere in
parte se io leggo la ricetta di questo
biscotto so che verrà un cookie al
cioccolato però non posso essere davvero
sicuro di quello che verrà
nel dettaglio se io prendo questi due
biscotti sono nati dallo stesso impasto
hanno lo stesso dna sono cotti nello
stesso forno se fossero due persone
sarebbero i due gemelli identici e
proprio come due gemelli identici non
sono esattamente uguali io li vedo da
vicino e mi rendo
conto che ci sono delle piccole
differenze chiunque conosca dei gemelli
identici sa che anche gemelli identici
non sono davvero identici questo perché
perché quando andiamo a vedere il dna di
una persona in realtà stiamo leggendo
una ricetta molte cose si possono capire
da una ricetta ma non possiamo avere la
certezza del prodotto finale
questo è molto importante perché ci dice
una cosa che dobbiamo ricordarci è un
messaggio che vorrei lasciarvi per
portarvi a casa il dna non è destino
molte cose che riguardano oggi la
genetica ci portano un po a credere a
pensare che tutto quello che siamo e
scritto nel nostro dna non è vero
proprio come in una ricetta noi se il
mio dna venisse trovato qui su questo
palco e potrebbero scoprire molte cose
su di me ma per esempio non potrebbero
misurare la mia intelligenza o capire se
sono predisposto alla matematica o a un
certo tipo di comportamento perché sono
caratteristiche complesse che dipendono
solo in parte dei geni e molto dall
ambiente in cui viviamo e quindi dal
forno in cui cresciamo questo significa
una cosa molto semplice che se il nostro
dna e una ricetta e non è destino
noi siamo molto più liberi e di quello
che pensiamo grazie
[Applauso]